Julie for more on this let's bring in
the former border patrol Chief Rodney
Scott Chief great to see you thank you
for taking time hope you had a good
Thanksgiving let's get right into these
numbers going all the way back to when
you were in charge going back to 2020
fiscal year just under 460
000 there then of course last fiscal
year uh 2022 it increased all the way to
record-breaking numbers nearly 2.4
million I am told already there's 350
000 encounters just this fiscal year
since October 1st what is your sense
when we hear uh the incoming uh minority
leader Kevin McCarthy who may presumably
be the speaker going to El Paso and
making statements like this I want to
get your reaction here's what he said
his actions have produced the greatest
wave of illegal immigration in recorded
history
if secretary mayorkas does not resign
House Republicans will investigate every
order
every action
and every failure
will determine whether we can begin
impeachment inquiry Chief should my
orcas resign or face impeachment
I believe if uh if my arc has had any
self credit if you had any credibility
at all or any Integrity he would resign
because people keep talking about we've
lost control of the Border that's that's
not necessarily true this Administration
willfully and intentionally gave up
control of the border that border was
never more secure than when this
Administration took over and even when
we did have surges there were meetings
every single day and we talked about how
can we how can we protect America by
slowing down this flow and making sure
we control who crosses the Border not
the cartels this Administration gave it
complete and total control of the border
to the Mexican cartels
the the secretary is responsible for
securing the border and he needs to be
held accountable uh he keeps saying the
border is more secure than ever and he
completely ignores what he gets briefed
on daily which is how many miles of
Border are not patrolled now how many
gotaways there are every single day and
then now we're talking about detailing
some Air Marshals to the Border you're
not going to rust your way out of this
problem this is a policy problem he
needs to detail judges to the Border he
needs to detain people that are crossing
the border until they've had due process
instead of releasing them and this
problem would go away overnight he needs
to be held accountable
and you heard McCarthy talking about
holding hearings so I want to ask you I
think you would be a great witness I
hope they call you when you retired you
wrote uh gave a extensive sort of
insight into why this was a national
security issue and obviously it has
gotten worse but but let me just ask you
who should McCarthy call to these border
hearings who needs to appear and and go
on record
I I think currently you know I have some
historical knowledge of course the
beginning of the administration and how
some of the decisions were were not made
but current government employees current
border Security Professionals within the
government they have the ins and outs
they know now what's going on more more
than even I do and they want to speak
out but they're under gag orders by this
Administration they're not allowed to
talk to reporters as you guys know you
hardly ever see any leadership from
career leadership from border patrol or
CBP or even ice speaking publicly
because this Administration doesn't want
the truth out there
I think those hearings should focus on
go ahead I'm just going to say I hope
that we ran out of time here Chief but I
hope they call the chiefs of all nine
border sectors and put them on record on
the muster rolls to find out how many
border patrol agents were on the line
protecting the nation and how many were
driving buses and babysitting with the
numbers they're coming across we've run
out of time Chief thank you as always
for your Insight and I hope to see you
at those hearings thank you sir
thank you I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis